[Musique]
bonsoir invité unique ô combien bernard
y pense fait-il que un garçon que nous
aimons bien qui a été mon invité il ya
quelques temps
roger carel paraissent avoir si peur de
vous il a raison d'avoir peur de moi je
crois que rocher car elle fait partie de
ces garçons qui ont reçu le plus de
gamelles de flotte sur la figure depuis
que la flotte existe par exemple si car
elle était l'aïe qui me voyaient avec un
verre d'eau ça donnerait sa guise les
vrais et il en irait s'il y avait
françois perrier avec moi non seulement
il sans rire et me déshabillerai la
façon ce camp nou lé pas ses vêtements
il vit dans la terreur quentinois tenue
tu en a plus beaucoup
alors y avait évidemment les canulars au
téléphone ça marche très bien c'est un
pelage et c'est très efficace surtout
manquons ses limites et le goût de jouer
oui enfin ça se passait tout de suite
après le retour de deux ouverts en
france en 45 et il devait grande
plaisanterie favorite à l'époque limité
bien jouer maintenant je peux
puissamment je me limite plus donc là
j'ai essayé de vous limiter un petit peu
et alors téléphoné à des comédiens à
quelle heure général heures du matin
sommeil ces veilleurs
alors ça donnait ça l'eau at elle dit
dans ici c'est mauvais qu'est-ce que tu
y aurait quelques ajouts des classiques
temps mondiaux n'a pas ce que je vous ai
parlé très gentiment comme ça dans
l'année oui mais ça n'intéresserait du
tartuffe avec nous mais oui m oui mais
alors dit moi quelque chose et artifices
et bien un petit peu un petit quelque
chose dit voit quelques maires pivot
quelques heures des molières et le gras
à 2 heures du matin heure du matin ça ne
ratez pas il partait dans sa tirade
c'était très méchant j'ai dit allez je
lui racontais à jour et qui manque les
communes est pas possible
il ya aussi les blagues qu'on se fait
dans les coulisses que le public ignore
mais provoque une certaine animation
joyeuse en 21 mois il m'est arrivé
d'aller saluer dans une pièce dont le
départ est qu'est-ce qu'elle était la
réaction du puits qui s'en apercevait
quand je suis allée saluer derrière
françois périer qui jouait au boss et
moi je jouais le petit bien fait dans un
autre théâtre que je finisse avant lui
et loris à lever tout seuls
et tout d'un coup il a senti que le
public s'amuser et applaudissait
chaleureusement et moi j'étais peut
mettre derrière je salue est derrière
vous utilisez le black
j'ai fait une fois
mais en coulisse veut dire entre les
loges souvent des communications a
reconnu pendant que joyon que lynette
je veux dire que lietz et encore une
pièce de marcel achard que j'ai joué
avec micheline presle et françois périer
encore une fois c'est une pièce clé dans
laquelle nous avons repris dès le
premier jour
même le soir de la générale on arrive on
a le trac mais là dans quel mystère
c'est pas à cause de quoi je ne sais pas
la pièce était un triomphe on a joué
deux ans mais pendant deux ans vous
pensez comme résultante de faire des
plaisanteries car son pain y avait dans
cette distribution une jeune femme
charmante qui n'a pas lycéen
impérissable dans la profession
c'est pour ça qu'on prenne nos cités
sans nom disons que la décote
en étant tout même très en dessous de la
vérité on lui faisait croire n'importe
quoi pendant deux ans par exemple s'ils
lisaient de lui dire vous ce que tu
racontes an passé mais qu'est ce que tu
racontes je te dis qu'à 18 ans une si
nina plus poitrine qu'est ce que vous
dites
diop elle s'est déshabillée pour te
prouver qu'on prenne ça marchait
régulièrement et on lui en a fait comme
ça pendant des années un jour ils lui
disent tu as vraiment très spécial
micheline presle et est jolie comme les
amours comme vous le savez et elle était
très courtisé par un monsieur qui était
fou d'elle et comme il avait raison il
eut envoyé des montagnes de fleurs il
avait une envoyé tellement de fleurs des
impôts micheline ne pouvait pas entrer
dans sa loge alors un soir michel pour
se préparer à une très grande robe
c'était compliqué a le plus de place
dans sa loge tellement il y avait de
fleurs elle sort un azalées grand comme
la table elle le met dans le couloir je
ne sais plus si françois o moi qui voit
là ali et qui va chez la copine en
question qui s'appelait noël de son
prénom
ne cherchez pas vous trouverez pas il
est des goûts de mastic noël ça fait des
années et des mois quand tu fais des
blagues on a voulu de faire plaisir aux
savez pas quoi offrir
on sait tous cotisés et honte à vous
faire vraiment c'est à l'équipe
merveilleuses le gentilé sibérie et tout
le monde enchaîne là dessus un un des
deux autres ou françois ozon mois sans
aucune préméditation ajoute tout le
monde l'a bien voulu donner sauf michée
rien n'était préparé je vous le jure
là dessus on appelle en scène michel
sort de sa loge doit s'en aller
elle fait vous avez de jolies fleurs
noël et l'autre lui répond
elles n'ont pas coûté cher
[Applaudissements]
5 absolument rien à ajouter vous avez
joué mauriac
j'ai failli j'ai failli jouer mauriac
parce qu'il m'avait demandé de jouer à
ce mode et qui était au répertoire de la
comédie-française et puis la commune i
français n'a pas voulu lâcher asmodée
pour des raisons qui ne doit jamais
rejoué et j'ai connu beaucoup m'ont rien
qui est un des hommes les plus drôles
que très déçu très inattendu bâton lee
mauriac datong ouest graphique il avait
précision le comique
je me souviens d'un mot de lui avec
perdu teigne je reviens à mon ami tu
perds tu aimes ce même seuil était
naturellement brouillé avec andré morgue
en nombre y a qu'à françois françois
mauriac pas été brouillées laurie moniez
fini avant tout le monde
c'est une querelle qui te raconter à
sarcelles au minimum
l'horrible bleus y sont tous les gens
vous avez connu mieux pas ça ce n'est
pas connu certains mais un soir berne
dany m'emmène à la générale à la
première d'une pièce de mauriac qui
s'appelait le passage du malin qui a été
jouée au théâtre de la madeleine et qui
a été un four épouvante malgré une
distribution très brillant et l'entente
la salle c'était la consternation
c'était affreux
certes au public pour les copains qui
jouaient et bernstein 10 qui buvait du
petit lait venez voir le poète et alors
on va en coulisse faire ce qu'on appelle
sacristie et berges des s'approche de
mauriac les deux mains tendues sachant
très bien que son ennemi intime avait
une catastrophe vous êtes content et
l'ofce
- vous raccourci permet à 8
est ce que vous faites comme eux
certains critiquent certains exégètes et
même certains hauts fonctionnaires
une démarcation entre le théâtre de
boulevard et puis le théâtre plus
ambitieux entre
ce qui fait rire et ce qu'ils en
pensaient là vous me mettez je vais me
[ __ ] en un type me parler de ça parce
que y'a mon avis il n'y a pas de théâtre
de boulevard mais par contient des
maisons de la culture
alors là je peux très bien tout en vous
reprochez aux maisons de culture mais je
reproche à par quelques-unes qui font du
très bon travail comme par exemple
maréchal à marseille je trouve que de
toucher les subventions impensable pour
monter des pièces ennuyeuse avec les
acteurs insuffisant devant des salles
vides ici retrouver à la fin de l'année
il ya quelque chose qui ne va pas si la
salle est vide de vie mal à bon non
parce qu'une salle vite c'est toujours
grave vous souvenez beaux vos plaques
avec le cher le regretté alfred un an
après la libération
ah oui on sort de la politique très long
mais il ya eu tout de suite après la
libération et a eu un climat spécial
j'adorais entrer dans les bistrots qui
avaient été des bistrots de marché noir
qui n'était plus ou presque plus alors
les gens avaient gardé l'habitude de
manger dans l'arrière boutique ou dans
l'arrière-salle et moi j'entrais dans la
première salle qui était vide et faisait
you may use et le trouble à toute
demande de figurer que c'était la
wehrmacht
leurs salles le 1er septembre 44 c'est
amusant enfin je vous remercie d'avoir
montré que un comédien
vous pouvez garder le sens du comique en
dehors des représentations que il
prenait son métier très au sérieux mais
lui même beaucoup moins
alors pour avoir été mon ami tu es ces
quelques jours merci bernard
[Musique]